mike is with us
mike is in oklahoma city hey mike
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you dave how are you doing sure
man what's up
yeah my uh my father passed away from
closing back on the ninth
oh no and yeah it's been kind of rough
for us
my mother inherited his 401k
and it's been his it's in his group plan
um they informed her she could keep it
in there
she retired he set free we
i don't we don't know what to do did we
roll it over
they did tell her that it would no
longer be managed by the assets
and neither one of us or has any
expertise in
in investing so i'm so sorry
how old was your dad 69
um that sounds younger every day
um okay
uh how much is in the 401k it's 720
000. okay 720
dollars yes okay
well this is um he also has a pension
in life that all of this is gonna be
coming in and we
have nobody to think we just kind of
figure out where we need to go
we know we just no we don't want to
touch it yeah we want it to grow
right and does your mom have an income
other than from this money that
that she can live on or do we need to
draw some off of this to for her to live
she she uh she received her social
security i think it's like
2 100 and something dollars a month and
that's plenty
for her like i said the house has paid
off
the first paid off he left in really
good shape and they were debt-free
they worked themselves out yeah out of
that well she needs to get more than two
thousand dollars a month man
i mean we need to we need to give her a
better life than that because she's a
millionaire
she is so tight i know but she needs to
lighten up and enjoy a little bit of it
and she she does not have to go hog wild
and lose
200 thousand dollars at the craps table
or something like that but she ought to
she ought to go and do some stuff and
buy some stuff
here or there and so i i would have you
draw a couple thousand dollars
additional off of this money a month
that's 24 000 a year that won't even
touch it
there's no possible way she could go
through this money in her lifetime
doing that but it would double her
quality of life and so let's do that for
mom
so what you need to do here's what
you're looking for
you are not and here's what you're not
looking for you are not looking for
a money manager an investment broker
who tells you what to do and you just go
along with whatever he or she says
because they have letters after their
name and a nice suit
this is how you lose all your money do
not do that
okay what you are looking for is an
investment
advisor that will teach you
and mom and it may take a little bit of
effort
and it may be difficult during this time
of grieving
so it's okay if you don't do anything
fancy at first
so here's here's a couple steps for you
that i would tell you to do
number one let's don't get in a hurry
on becoming an investment uh uh expert
you're not going to be one in 20 minutes
okay okay
let yourself off the hook but also don't
just turn it over to somebody because
they're smart and you think you're dumb
that's how people lose all their money
like those athletes that lost all their
money that's what they did
that was one of the anxiety points for
me to trust somebody that did
you don't do that it's not their money
it's your mom's money
you trust you and your mom okay and the
way you can trust you is you're gonna
learn so here's some steps that
allow you to move slowly and carefully
so rule number ones don't go fast rule
number two is don't invest money and
anything you don't understand which
means you can't go fast because it's
going to take you a while to understand
okay okay that's okay no shame in that
at all
first time you drove the car you don't
need to drive it fast that's all right
right yes yes put the tractor in the
back field let the bush hawk down and
put it in granny gear and turn them
loose right
you can't mess nothing up you know what
i'm saying absolutely
just go slow all right now so go to
daveramsey.com click on smart investor
pro
put in the information it'll drop down a
list of the pros in your area
you can interview as many of them as you
want and then you select the one that
you like the best and your mom likes the
best
and go with the way your mom she needs
to
use words like i like that guy
he feels safe
okay the way the way her spirit reacts
to the person
is going to be a really good indicator
does that make sense
yes yes it does and that's not so that
you trust them to do stuff blindly
it's you trust them to teach you the
last step after go
slow and don't put money in anything you
don't understand the last step is
with all financial people especially in
a situation like this where you feel
inept
because you are you are looking not for
a salesperson you are looking for
a teacher they have to have the heart of
a teacher
and you will know you have met with a
teacher if after you leave their office
you have learned something
gotcha now i would suggest that you roll
this 401k
and the pension into a simple money
market
account with a smartvestor pro that's
just a savings account like a bank
it's gonna pay almost nothing like one
percent they suck
but they're a hundred percent safe and
it's just like opening a bank account
you can do that you already understand
that right then
park your emotions and give you mom a
little time to grieve
this is really fresh yeah it is
and then have another meeting with the
smartvestor pro in another meeting with
the smartmister pro in another meeting
with smartvisterpro
and sometime around september you will a
have learned enough and b have given
yourself time to cry enough
that your brain is no longer in a fog
and you can begin the investing process
and moving some of it into mutual funds
okay
gotcha but you need to learn about it
and you need to have a clear mind and
no one loses your mom and dad were
married a long time
yes and he was a good provider he cared
for him yeah cared for you guys
yeah and you know it's just your your
brain your mama's my
brain for sure yours too but your mama's
even more so is in a fog of grief right
now and that's not when you make 700 000
decisions
you just put in a savings account over
at that smart vista pro get out of that
company
get away from them just park it there
give yourself time to breathe
john yeah and and make sure most
sons want to go in and fix everything
that's the way they're gonna honor their
dad i want you to also make sure you
take time to grieve too
make sure you've got some buddies you
can talk to make sure you've got some
people in your life that you can sit
down and just say
i miss my old man and this sucks and
that you can cry as well
yeah okay i'm so sorry you guys are
going through this but those are your
steps
go slow don't put money in things you
don't understand
and always hire financial people with
the heart of a teacher
those are your three rules